hello my name is Pete Geren chip and I'm
a senior level designer at CD Projekt
RED The Witcher Wild Hunt is an
open-world fantasy game where you take
the role of a Witcher a professional
monster slayer gerelds mission is to
find a child of prophecy a weapon that
can save or destroy this world it's an
adventure of epic proportions we'll give
you a little taste of it in a form of a
side quest
let's head to a nearby village and earn
some money the magic spell creates an
area that slows time for our enemies one
of the many tricks you can learn when
you level up your character you're not
gonna have your day ruined by a couple
of wolves
you go north master why do you ask
I thought you could see if anything's
happened to our men they've been gone a
while
what do you need merchant Caravan came
through not long past hired some of our
boys to guide him to the bridge they
were due back yesterday fine keep my
eyes open the brother Tamil Adam talk to
him when you find the clever man not
like the rest of them eh
it seems that this Caravan never reached
a village let's get on a horse and look
for it
go go when you're outside you can always
whistle to call a horse it's one of the
faster ways to traverse the massive
landscape of The Witcher Wild Hunt
no man's land the huge area around us
has a multitude of interesting places
and events that you can stumble upon
during your travels
a witcher's equipped with a variety of
mutations The Witcher senses come very
useful when tracking down your target
someone walked through the spilled wine
kid when smell linger for hours
The Witcher senses allow you to follow
the most subtle of tracks invisible for
the mortal eye
drags on to the cave
got one just before you reach the cave
boy Creve your eyes to showing so in the
dark sword at first it with a lizard
coming thing that attacked how big was
it well too big to squeeze in here you
were huge and those teeth yeah we barely
escaped wonder if it killed the traders
poor son sure of it comin important
thing now to get out here will he help
master Witcher need to tend to the
monster doubt I'll have to look for
wyverns like to herd their prey towards
their nests will white here wouldn't
want to get in your way
royal wyvern lucky me apparently we are
facing a hefty challenge let's look for
the monsters nest
the wyvern is a formidable enemy
definitely stronger than wolves
preparing for the upcoming battle is key
to our success for this particular fight
it seems like a smart move to apply an
oil that enhances your damage of your
sword of choice
there's got to be a big bounty for this
a Witcher has to be careful when
fighting a big monster simple mistakes
can cost you a lot of health what now
keep your distance and look out for
special attacks
magic spells have a cool-down that
prevents you from using them all the
time level them up for more power and
shorter cooldowns
sometimes monsters have special attacks
like the acidic spit of the royal wiper
mashing buttons will rarely breathe
victory
unfortunately you have many skills and
expertise up your sleeve
it's huge
what's the name again royal wyvern don't
usually come this big it's feasted
plenty I reckon attacking those
traveling the road
what are they call ye master Geralt of
Rivia Geralt of Rivia it'll be a tale to
tell the young uns
never forget to take your trophy when
you defeat a monster of this size
at this point you could head for the
village for reward let's just take a
quick moment to appreciate the scenery
there's a vast open world for you to
explore the northern kingdoms offer over
a hundred hours of pure adventure go go
gets ready to enter the world of The
Witcher Wild Hunt
you